[Musica]
[Applauso]
quattro anni fa in una bella domenica di
aprile
mi imbatto in un articolo di giornale
vengo folgorata dalle immagini di una
donna ratificata alla roccia allo
sguardo diretto alla cima e capelli
liberi al vento intorno a lei
uno scenario di montagna e mozzafiato
siamo in iran e lei una donna iraniana
capace di aprire nuove vie sulle pareti
di roccia
da quel momento rimango colpita in
maniera fatale da questa immagine e
decido di valori incontrare questa donna
e di andare a conoscere la sua storia da
vicino raccontandola in un documentario
non sono la d'iran se non che c'è un
codice di condotta molto ferreo per le
donne
non so molto di arrampicata quasi nulla
la montagna però è il mio punto fermo
cento che una dimensione che mi attrae
più di ogni altra cosa
infatti la montagna e il luogo delle
sfide con se stessi è una dimensione
fatale è il luogo capisco delle domande
e mentre inizio questo viaggio di
avvicinamento verso questa donna lontana
rifletto le storie che ci venga
sono raccontate sono al novanta per
cento storie realizzate da registi
uomini le donne registe al mondo sono
una minoranza agghiacciante
forse perché la regia sicuramente un
urlo al apicale e quindi un lavoro dove
il soffitto di cristallo rimane sulla
testa delle donne
mi domando se la modalità in cui questa
posizione e cosa li data cioè quella del
decisionismo delle idee chiare sia
l'unica modalità che non ce ne sia
un'altra più interlocutoria dialogica
che ugualmente sia efficace nel processo
creativo e mentre i due progetti da
personale diventa pubblico viene
lanciata una campagna di raccolta fondi
che galvanizza gli amici ei sostenitori
e mi porta a raggiungere l'obiettivo
in breve tempo peccato però che le
sanzioni americane contro l'iran
colpiscono questo piccolo progetto e i
nostri soldi vengono congelati per mesi
e non ne sappiamo più nulla fino a che
verranno restituiti a tutti i donatori
non ci fermiamo però abbiamo intenzione
di andare avanti dei produttori ci
riescono
e così iniziamo la prima parte delle
riprese che vengono svolte in italia
perché i sogni a quel punto è di portare
nasim ad aprire una nuova via sulle alpi
e così per giorni siamo impegnati
riprese in alta quota che non sono
facili questo è sicuro però non mi
sembrano la parte più difficile del
nostro programma infatti c'è una
montagna nascosta che anche stiamo
scalando che è quella di provare a
raccontare la verità di una donna
iraniana proviene da un paese dove la
condotta
delle donne è gestita e organizzata in
maniera molto precisa e vincolante per
cui mi pongo il problema
con questo racconto su di lei un
racconto vero di integrità di poterla
mettere in difficoltà in pericolo
e questa cosa ci unisce ci unisce ancora
di più nel senso che si crea una
dinamica di fiducia reciproca che ci fa
diventare vere compagni ricordata come
montagne e sarà appunto quando la
raggiungerò in iran e la seguirò nelle
modalità che lei mi permette mi consente
seguiremo un basso bassissimo profilo
che ci fa partire senza permessi e che
fa desistere un certo numero di
operatori di ripresa nel seguirmi quando
poi ci troveremo in iran
anche l'operatore che è venuto con me a
un certo punto mi dà la telecamera in
mano e alcune riprese negli spazi
pubblici sarò io a farlo adesso
io mi sento in realtà immune alle
difficoltà
io ho una missione da compiere e la devo
fare anche in breve tempo ho lasciato a
casa tre figli e una madre malata e devo
arrivare in fondo senza rinunciare
infatti noi donne troviamo sempre molti
motivi per rinunciare motivi validissimi
che ci fanno mettere da parte dei
progetti molto più personali ma siamo
anche molto brave a conciliare e credo
che dobbiamo mettere nell'agenda delle
priorità proprio quei progetti che
sembrano così poco necessari man de rita
ci permettono davvero di realizzare noi
stessi e così è nato fin su una donna
che vince la paura di cadere dalla
montagna e nella lotta con la forza
di gravità dove si sente che porta giù
tutti donne uomini poveri ricchi
allo stesso modo trova uno spazio di
uguaglianza che la verifica e così sono
arrivata sulla cima di questa montagna
con da si è vinto la paura di non
riuscire lassù il panorama è bellissimo
e di sorso beth fithen tuo figlio
islamic republic of iran
il suo amico
ennesimo atto cosa rimane fra cui il
rais feedback
il management gravity bulls air force
[Musica]
guarda che pentirmi
del popolo vinci
[Musica]
online
mai